Politico reveals bombshell new report
about the left's treatment of anti feh
under President Obama we will talk about
that we will also be getting to Donald
Trump giving a million dollars to
hurricane Harvey victims and why the
left is now desperate for the Russia
investigation to pan out even more
desperate than they were before I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
many of things to talk about today plus
we're gonna get to the mailbag but
before we do any of that first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Mack Weldon dot-com so Mack walden is
better than whatever you are wearing
right now they believe in smart design
premium fabrics simple shopping they
make underwear socks shirts under shirts
hoodies sweat pants more more quality
than you will ever wear the eyewear mech
Weldon underwear and they are just super
comfortable not only a super comfortable
they're really durable you know you go
out and you buy some cheap underwear and
they fall apart in like five seconds you
have to throw in the garbage map Wheldon
underwear are super durable I've been
wearing them not the same ones every day
guys but I'm wearing Mac Walden
underwear for months now and they feel
the same as when they came out of the
package they are also naturally
antimicrobial which means that they
eliminate odor they want you to be
comfortable so if you don't like a first
pair then you can keep it and they will
still refund you no questions asked they
perform well they look good you can wear
it in you can wear it out when you go
home I don't dress like this when I go
home I actually get into comfortable
clothes and I always put on my Mac
welding gear that's the best gear you
can have math Wheldon comm get 20% off
using promo code Shapiro
that's Mac Weldon comm use promo code
Shapiro get 20% off again it spelled ma
CK Weldon wel do and comm knack Wells
and comm use that promo code Shapiro get
20% off and let them know that we sent
you as well okay so president Trump he
he made a statement yesterday that I was
kind of surprised he hadn't done earlier
actually he said that who's gonna give a
bunch of money to the hurricane Harvey
victims which makes an awful lot of
sense the man's incredibly wealthy and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders made that
announcement yesterday and so here is
what Sarah Huckabee Sanders had to say
about it I had a chance to speak
directly with the president earlier and
I'm happy to tell you that he is would
like to join in the efforts that a lot
of the people that we've seen across
this country do and he's
pledging $1,000,000 of personal money to
the fun and he's actually asked that I
check with the folks in this room since
you are very good at research and have
been doing a lot of recording into the
groups and organizations that have best
and most effective in helping and
providing aid and he'd love some
suggestions from the folks here and I'd
be happy to take those if any of you
have them smart for a president Trump to
do this obviously it's good PR it makes
a lot of sense meanwhile the Democrats
are looking at this and they're
realizing that Trump's handling of
hurricane Harvey's actually pretty good
most Americans are gonna be pretty happy
with how he has handled this natural
disaster it's better frankly than I
thought he was going to handle a natural
disaster I thought his administration
did a better job than I thought that
they might do so I really have no major
complaints with President Trump here I
think that he's doing a pretty good job
unifying the country around the
hurricane Harvey victims again easy
thing to unify around but I think that
he's done a good job with it Democrats
however are still focused on how do we
stop Trump how do we stop the
Republicans and so the way they're are
attempting to do this is by painting the
Republicans as divisive Bernie Sanders
came out yesterday he says that he hopes
the president's from stops dividing and
also he hopes that someone will at some
point give him finally after long last a
pudding Cup
preferably tapioca but if you do not
have it he will also take vanilla he
does not like chocolate go Bernie
Sanders that in Houston right now people
don't care whether you're black - you're
white or you're Latino or you're gay or
you're straight people are helping each
other which is what this country is
supposed to be about people in use that
are coming together and hope Trump stops
dividing up the American people
okay so let's point something out it's
not Trump at this point he's dividing
the American people Trump is responding
the way he's supposed to be responding
and it's Sanders who is suggesting the
divisions and when it comes to the
divisive rhetoric stuff when it comes to
the idea that Trump is the only one
who's engaged in divisive rhetoric this
is not what about ISM okay I've been
very very critical of President Trump's
rhetoric I've criticized him for not
disassociating himself from the all
right I think I've been pretty clear on
this for the last two years at this
point that I think a lot of President
Trump's rhetoric is designed to divide
rather than to unite and I don't like
that part of his rhetoric that is
designed to do that without actually
naming an enemy you know so I've been
clear about that that said the idea that
the left is proposed
that Trump is the divider and they are
the great uniter this is absolute
nonsense this is a report from Politico
and it's an amazing report that's gonna
go under notice today which is why we're
gonna bring attention to it on this the
most popular podcast on the right in
America so here is the here's the story
from Politico and they reported on
Friday the federal government has been
worrying about the rise of anti feh this
is this leftist quasi domestic terror
group since early 2016
now 2017 like most people became aware
of an Tifa in 2017 when an Tifa burned a
bunch of crap at AU nappa love speech at
berkeley but an Tifa had been very
active in 2016 they had engaged in
violent riots in in Sacramento there was
a riot in Sacramento we talked to a
member of one of the groups that was
attending that rallies a white
supremacist reality they're a bunch of
people who showed up to the corner
unquote defend the rights of the white
supremacists and Antipa showed up ready
to do violence when this when this
happened it was not covered by the media
but that happened in the middle of 2016
in Sacramento at the State Capitol
apparently the federal government has
had reports on an Tifa since early 2016
even labeled their activities domestic
terrorist violence do you remember Obama
saying anything about it in 2016
anything did he say one word about an
Tifa or left-wing violence in 2016 no I
didn't think so so we've got in two
years of President Trump must
disassociate himself from the all right
and white supremacist violence of course
I agree everyone should have no problem
doing that right or left but the left
including President Obama hasn't had to
do anything until now right Nancy Pelosi
gave a statement this week talking about
how antifa was bad where were they last
year why didn't they stop this thing
when it was rising according to Politico
quote previously unreported documents
disclosed that by April 2016 authorities
believe that anarchist extremists were
the primary instigators of violence at
public rallies against a range of
targets okay again that language primary
instigators
it's an leftist played this is though
it's a cycle of violence it's the white
supremacist show up with a brick and the
antiva people show up with a bat they go
at each other it is an Tifa that has
provokes these clashes and then a lot of
these white supremacist groups a lot of
zealot right groups show up and they
look for violence as well but the ones
who are instigating this largely are
antifa
that's not according to me that's
according to the FBI and the Department
of Homeland Security they were blamed by
authorities for attacks on the police
government and political
institutions along with symbols of the
capitalist system racism social and
justice and fascism according to a
confidential 2016 joint intelligence
assessment by the DHS and the FBI the
violence ratcheted up as president
Trump's campaign and swung into full
gear
the FBI noted violence by an Tifa in
Texas Oregon California law enforcement
in particular focus on a white
supremacist rally in Sacramento after
Sacramento rally antiva protesters came
looking for violence and quote engaged
in several activities indicating
proficiency in pre operational planning
to include organizing carpools to travel
from different locations
raising bail money and preparation for
arrests counter surveilling a law
enforcement using three man's scout
teams using handheld radios for
communication coordinating the event via
social media according to the DHS that's
a planning that's planning's and just
punch - spontaneous violence this is
people on handheld radios learning each
other when the cops are showing up
they've raised bail money in
anticipation of arrests they were
organizing carpools to get to and from
places they were organizing how to get
weapons the FBI and DHS issued a report
in April 2016 openly saying that Antipa
was prepping for violence New Jersey law
enforcement reportedly stated that an
teef had cropped up in New York Chicago
San Francisco and Philly
shockingly some members of an Tifa quote
have gone overseas to train and fight
with fellow and artist organizations he
sounds like a terror cell going overseas
to train and fight with anarchist
organization so here is the question
this was happening in the middle of 2016
where the hell was President Obama and
the violence in Charlottesville
President Trump was asked repeatedly as
well he should have been denounced this
violence and he did repeatedly denounced
the violence and then he said there was
violence on both sides and the media
want nuts
over that particular statement there's a
lot more in the press conference that
was bad but that was correct there was
violence on both sides and Antipa was
causing a lot of it where was Obama for
a year
anytime there was a violent incident
Obama tended to downplay the violence
and instead talk about the underlying
root causes of the violence and he got
away with it
remember in April 2009 it's amazing the
double standard that holds for the right
and the left okay so there's this report
that comes out from the FBI and DHS
April 2016 talking about the violence of
antiva flashback before that seven years
okay it's now April 2009 shortly after
Obama takes office and then
Hartman of Homeland Security under the
auspices of Janet Napolitano who's now
in charge of the University of
California system issued a report saying
that white right-wing extremism was on
the rise
labeling anti-abortion anti immigration
groups a suspect the report specifically
called out the prospect of lone-wolf
terrorism from those who agreed with
quote-unquote right-wing viewpoints the
report was really vague but the Obama
administration stood by it so how about
his apparently very specific report
regarding an even from the year of the
election not a word from the Obama
administration we're only finding out
about it a year and a half after it
happened a year and a half and let's
contrast the language of that 2009 memo
with the language of the Obama
administration regarding political
violence the 2009 memo about right-wing
violence it says quote debates over
appropriate immigration levels and
enforcement policy generally fall within
the realm of protected political speech
under the First Amendment but in some
cases anti-immigration or strident Pro
enforcement fervor has been directed
against specific groups and has the
potential to turn violent has the
potential to turn violent what does that
even mean has the potential to turn
violent that's vague but the Obama
administration stood by it but when
left-wing rhetoric actually turned
violent what did Obama do he said all
the violence is bad but they do have
some grievances don't they I'm speaking
specifically about President Obama's
speech in July 2016 after a black
radical parroting black lives matter
talking points went out and murdered
five police officers and wounded seven
others in Dallas
the officers were protecting the black
lives matter March at the time Obama
actually spent an inordinate amount of
time echoing BLM's message at their
funeral service at their funeral service
imagine if President Trump had actually
gone out after Charlottesville and he
had said and he sort of did do this to a
certain extent the media went nuts you
remember that he went out and he said
listen this violence is terrible but
Confederate statues right there's the
legit arguments we had over a
Confederate statue the media went
completely nuts here's what Obama said
at the funeral four people who were
murdered by a black lives matter
supporter a black radical who was
echoing the talking points of black
lives matter here's what he said quote
we know the bias remains we know it
whether you're black or white or
Hispanic or Asian or Native American or
of Middle Eastern descent we've all seen
this bigotry in our own lives at some
point we've heard at it we've heard it
at times in our homes if we're honest
perhaps we've heard prejudice in our own
heads and felt it in our own hearts and
he talked about how the cops are a bunch
of racists amazing
the treatments okay but not one peep
about empty thought not one peep about
antiva I want to talk a little bit more
about that and how the Democrats are
really split now between their radicals
and their moderates and their only hope
left is getting President Trump and how
they hope to do that but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. CCA so many of you understand
that in the end protecting yourself and
your family is your responsibility if
you're ever forced to defend yourself
your wife your kid it's a decision you
make on the spot you know there's an
instant when you know that you're gonna
have to pull the trigger and many of us
to know we would act but we wouldn't
really have thought about what comes
after because the cops show up they may
arrest you you may end up having to
fight it out with the authorities you
need protection from the law and that's
why you need to get self-defence
insurance from the US CCA they'll
support you with a hundred percent
upfront coverage for criminal defense
civil suits and bail funding they have a
24/7 critical response team local
attorney coordination and more for all
of that go to defend my family now calm
let's defend my family now calm for
coverage starting at only $13 per month
we know that we will defend our loved
ones but we should also defend our loved
ones against the the problems that come
after having to defend them activate
your membership today it's offending my
family now calm again its defend my
family now calm you get a
limited-edition range bag completely
free which is pretty cool
defend my family now calm go over there
register and again you get that range
bag completely free the limited-edition
range bags that's pretty awesome plus
you get the insurance coverage which is
something that everybody should have go
out and check out our friends at the
u.s. concealed carry Association us CCA
defend my family now calm okay so again
the left needs to be asked every
Democrat needs to be asked about ends
heat at this point they should have been
asked about it a year ago they should
have been grilled about it a year ago
they should have been grilled about it
after what happened in Sacramento but
the media was too ensconced in its
narrative of antifa as Normandy fighters
to actually go out and fight violence
that's despicable that's truly
despicable and you can see the split
that's happening now inside the
Democratic Party between the so-called
moderates and the radicals the radicals
are still saying well let's see if it
has a point they're not so bad and the
moderates who are now being led by Nancy
Pelosi of all people they're saying
auntie was really bad
if the Democrats don't come together
around this I think it's indicative of a
broader split inside the Democratic
Party the far left of the Democratic
Party is even further left in Bernie
Sanders they're moving left at an
increasingly rapid pace the Democratic
Party has split and the old-school
Hillary Clinton quote-unquote moderate
Democratic Party which was never
moderate they were being left in the
wake even Bernie Sanders is now being
seen increasingly as a guy who's not
radical enough I've never seen a party
move this far to one extreme this fast
and you can see it happening in real
time and Tifa is accelerating that Trump
is certainly accelerating that the
left's hatred for Trump is driving them
off the rails every Democrat should now
be asked will you denounce the antifa
Louie's announced them I think marthy
sin has a great piece of Washington Post
and it's it is interesting it's
fascinating how white supremacists who
get violent white supremacist who get
violent they are seen as the ultimate
evil totally fair they are an ultimate
evil left wing extremists who get
violent you know I'm talking about
Communists and anarchists they're seen
as somehow superior to Nazis which is
weird to me I mean the Communist more
responsible for a couple hundred million
deaths over the course of the last
century they as Marc Thiessen said I'm
not sure why it is that somebody who
gets violence in American streets
carrying the flag of Stalin is better
than somebody that's violent in American
streets carrying the flag of Hitler
these both seem like terrible people and
there is a moral equivalence there and I
think that's right now communism is an
ideology that is just as evil as Nazism
in its own way it's not racist the way
the Nazism was but it is certainly
classist I mean these are people who
suggested that people who are bushwa be
murdered hey that you could separate
people based on class it's funny how
both of these groups seems to censor
when it comes down to it they both come
down on the same side when it comes to
the Jewish Question neither of them
really like the Jews very much Stalin
wasn't really fond and neither was
Hitler but it is amazing how we in the
United States we've taken the sort of
sanguine view of communism in a way that
we never have with Nazism even though
they were both at the time cheered by
Democrats at the time the the Nazi
movement was seen as sort of a proto
fascist or fascist proto forerunner of a
more sophisticated movement that
eventually could be used for good by a
lot of people including some mainstays
of the democratic
back in the day so again the only point
to be made here is that we ought to be
looking at the violence on both sides
and condemning it and condemning the
ideology that underlies it but instead
what we're seeing is some people on the
Left condemning the violence not all and
very few people on the left condemning
the ideology at all whereas everybody on
the right who has any brain at all is
condemning white supremacist in the all
right okay so what does this mean
Democrats have to know this stuff
doesn't make them popular okay the
Antipa stuff is not going to make them
popular it's not gonna make them
well-loved it makes them seem extreme
and crazy because they're being extreme
and crazy and so instead what they are
focusing in on is their final hope the
last hope right their very last hope of
all is beyond from destroying himself is
Robert Muller so Robert Muller is the
special investigator and now there's
some new developments in Robert Miller's
case again they need to shut down these
leaks these leaks are just ridiculous so
here is here is the report from media I
this is this is from yesterday from
Joseph Wolfson the team of Special
Counsel Robert Muller is reportedly
collaborating with New York Attorney
General Eric Schneiderman in it's an
ongoing investigation according to a new
report from Politico Muller's team and
Schneiderman's office have been in
contact in recent weeks exchanging
information and evidence on former Trump
campaign manager Paul Manafort and his
financial transactions anonymous sources
familiar with the collaboration have
said they're potentially building a
criminal case possibly for money
laundering but no decision has been made
whether or not charges will be filed
nothing is imminent one source told
Politico as political reports
Schneiderman can potentially provide
Muller additional leverage to get Man
afford to cooperate with his
investigation noting that President
Trump does not have pardoning power over
state crime so here is the difficulty
here so everybody has been talking about
Trump can always just pardon anybody who
is convicted or anybody who's indicted
not true state crimes if you are
condemned of murder in a state court you
cannot be pardoned by the president you
can only be pardoned by the governor so
what does that mean what it looks like
he looks like Robert Muller is
coordinating with Eric Schneiderman the
very political very left Attorney
General of the state of New York to go
after Paul Manafort who as I've said
before is pretty corrupt and then use
those state charges as a way to get
Manafort to flip on Trump that could be
what's happening here right you have
Sneiderman charged man affordance
Court and then say we'll drop those
charges if you testify against Trump and
Trump can't pardon Manta fort and just
get out of that conundrum that'd be very
clever by Muller if that's what he
intends on doing but it's very dangerous
for President Trump obviously because
sitting around waiting to be to be to
have your former campaign chair indicted
at the state level and then see where
that ends up is very dangerous game a
lot of people are suggesting that based
on this Trump should fire Muller that
would be the biggest disaster of all
right now there's a game of chicken
going on Muller is going as far as you
can almost hearing Trump to fire him if
Trump's fires him all hell will break
loose it's gonna be very difficult for
Republicans to stand up in the face of
President Trump firing the special
investigator who's looking into election
corruption that's not the only story
involving Muller today according Betsy
Woodruff from The Daily Beast special
counsel Bob Muller has teamed up with
the IRS according to sources familiar
with his investigation into alleged
Russian election interference his probe
has enlisted the help of agents from the
IRS is Criminal Investigations unit this
unit known as CI is one of the federal
government's most tight-knit specialized
secretive investigative entities it has
2,500 agents focusing exclusively on
financial crime including tax evasion
and money laundering the IRS does have
access to Trump's tax returns potential
financial crimes are a central part of
Muller's probes that is part of the
thing Trump has said in the past that
that would be the red line for him as if
Muller started looking into financial
dealings of his family and Muller said
screw that I'm looking wherever I please
and there's a problem too which is that
Trump has not actually staffed up the
IRS right Trump has not actually staffed
up the IRS this is according to Daily
Beast the team up between the IRS and
Muller probe could come with political
complications Muller has already taken
some criticism for the number of
Democratic donors on his team those
critiques intensified yesterday after
the announcement about Schneiderman also
it is pretty clear that Trump has not
filled out a lot of the senior positions
at these particular at these particular
agencies where Trump has not yet named
his pick to run the tax division which
is a post that require Senate
confirmation and also a post which could
help out Muller in his investigation so
right now and Obama appointee is filling
the slot that can work with Muller to
give him the information
so Muller can get all the dirt that he
wants right now Trump has put himself in
the situation because remember it was
Trump's activity regarding James Comey
it was his dragging in of Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein that led
to the appointment of the special
counsel in the first place now if he
fires the special counsel it'll look
like a cover-up so it's a full-scale
problem for President Trump at this
point a lot of people saying well I
should just fire people and get it over
with
and that way they can't have grounds to
impeach him again impeachment is a
political grounds I think his best move
here is to wait it out and I honestly
think that that he's actually innocent
of the Russia collusion I don't think
that Trump himself was colluding with
Russia I think that there is a
possibility that manna fort was working
with the Russians because Nana forts
always work with the Russians I think
there is the possibility that Flynn was
doing so but the idea that Trump knew
about it is a whole different thing so
you could easily see a scenario where
Trump's underlings go down and it looks
more like iran-contra that it looks like
Watergate it looks a lot more like
somebody underneath Trump goes down then
like the President himself goes down and
that's why I'm saying that I don't think
Trump should fire Muller but what
Mulder's doing is obviously provocative
but Muller is doing is obviously
aggressive and so he must think that
he's got something the Democrats
obviously are just ecstatic about this
MSNBC's Mark Halperin he says Muller is
a ruthless opponent and is not afraid of
President Trump Muller is a cyborg with
a head of heart and a brain I mean this
is this is it this is an opponent unlike
he's a cyborg who has a head of heart
and a brain okay he's a relentless
opponent and one of the underappreciated
aspects of how he's building this
operation I think is his ability because
of his vast experience to coordinate
he's in sync with the congressional
investigations whose investigators and
members are not issuing you know
immunity the people are bringing up
witnesses who will interfere with the
case he's coordinating within the
Justice Department the FBI you don't
hear any unhappiness coming from there
and now he's coordinating with another
guy with subpoena power another guy who
is fearless and not afraid of Donald
Trump and a guy who can bring charges
that the president can't pardon for none
of this is that accident we're seeing
through a glass darkly what does Muller
operations like we see only a tiny bit
of it but it's clear from everything we
see that there is a strategy here
there's a there's a fearlessness and
there's a core level of coordination
that makes anyone trying to help the
President on this be put in a very
defensive position okay so you can see
the excitement from the media and all
this and we'll talk a little bit more
about the excitement from some fake news
people like actual fig news people in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to the sponsors over at tides
of history this is a brand new podcast
it is just fantastic
Google tides of history for more
information okay so what is it it's all
about why we have States countries taxes
Wars all of these institutions go back
hundreds and hundreds of years when did
when did globalization start why does
practically every government on earth
followed the same basic organization
wondering has a new podcast from PhD
historian Patrick Wyman he also happens
to be an MMA analyst by the way it's
called tides of history and it answers
these questions he looks at the time
periods covering the fall of Rome and
the rise of the early modern empire
so about 1350 to 1650 he talked about
the roots of the modern world where all
of these socio-cultural structures we
interact with came from why do we have
States all of these questions can be
traced back to this particular period
it's really entertaining he breaks down
what could be dry history into really
fascinating stuff if you love learning
and I do then you need to go check out
tides of history wondrous new podcast
tides of history really fantastic go
listen the first episode on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen to
podcasts and Google tides of history for
more information I do highly recommend
the podcast it really is quite good I
like listening to other people's podcast
I recommended one yesterday this is the
one that I recommend today tides of
history I would recommend it by the way
whether or not they were sponsored
because it is that good it's a very very
good podcast tides of history go check
it out over at wandering or any other
place that that that you can get your
podcast ok so we're going to talk some
more about all of this plus I want to
get to the mailbag but for all of that
you're gonna have to go over to to daily
we're calm right now and become a
subscriber for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe to daily whitey and get the
rest of this show live you can get the
rest of manic Levens show live you can
get the rest of michael Knowles's show
live all three of those shows are huge
and growing you can also get the the
website ad free later when we post those
shows all of the ads are taken out so
you can listen to the shows ad free as
well which is pretty cool plus if you go
over and get an annual subscription
right now for $99 a year you got this
the finest of all tumblers
the leftist here is hot or cold daily
wire mug it is unsurpassed in its
quality unsurpassed nothing finer has
ever been created on this earth there
are diamonds that could not cut this
thing it is just unbelievable leftist
here is hot or cold the daily wire by
the way if the diamond doesn't cut this
it's not a real lemon in any case
leftist here's how I'll get that for $99
annual subscription go check it out or
if you just want to listen later go over
to iTunes or SoundCloud make sure you
subscribe leave us a review always helps
us with the rankings on iTunes and we
always appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so the the Democrats are obviously
ecstatic about these new developments in
Malloy they're placing all their hope in
Muller I don't think my waters gonna
give them what they want I don't think
this is gonna come down to some major
indictments of President Trump or even
anyone who is super close to him but you
can see the excitement on the left
they're so excited they think that
finally there will be a magic bullet
okay when you are relegating to hoping
that a magic bullet is gonna take out
the president I mean literally when
you're relegated to hope it I shouldn't
take me out you pull in association with
presidents because that's actually a
thing with JFK but when you're relegated
to hoping that something bad is going to
take the president out let just some
random event is gonna take the president
out some random story then you're in
serious trouble I know this because
there are a lot of people on the right
who are attempting to push the birther
story back in 2012 hoping that suddenly
there would be evidence that that Obama
was not actually eligible for office and
then you'd have to leave office and I
know a lot of good-hearted people got
taken in by this because Obama wouldn't
release his birth certificate I always
thought it was stupid I always thought
it was unsubstantiated I always thought
there was no evidence of it but there
are a lot of people who bought into it
or at least left their mind open to it
because there's a hopeful thing that oh
maybe there'll be a maybe there will be
a deus ex machina that some something
will come from the sky and knock Obama
out you can see the Democrats doing the
same thing with the Muller investigation
right now dan Rather who is the very
definition of fake news he came out
yesterday and he spoke about hurricane
Vladimir right under the Putin the Putin
story is gonna take out Trump and what
you seeing behind after time is a
president who is within himself seized
with fear and that's gonna be you know a
political hurricane is out there at sea
for him we'll call it hurricane Vladimir
if you will the whole Russian thing it's
still pretty far out at sea but each
each day and tonight we saw it again
with the two things you reported the
Russian reporting from Politico and the
Financial Times this hurricane this
political hurricane it's still far out
at sea is building an intensity because
say well it was category largest
category one's going to get it over to
its approaching category for don't
stretch hasn't met a metaphor too far
but that's nothing says classy quite
like in the middle of a category four
hurricane hitting the main
United States likening a political
scandal to a hurricane that's going to
take out the President of the United
States just very classy stuff from a guy
who lost his job in 2004 for
legitimately making up a document or
pushing a forged document about
President Bush he thought this is the
irony he thought in 2004 that that was
going to be the magic the magic bullet
that ended up destroying the Bush
presidency that he was going to release
this letter about Bush going AWOL it
turned out that was fake virtually any
time somebody says I have the magic tape
I have the magic thing that's gonna take
out the president only once only once in
American history really has there been
some sort of magic document magic tapes
that ended up taking down a president
was Nixon and so everybody wants to go
back to that model that was that was
something that was was unique in
American history I don't think you're
gonna see something like that again in
the near future but you can see that the
hopes of the Democrats are riding on
this thing Keith Olbermann is saying the
same thing he says everyone in the
cabinets gonna be a peach not only is
Trump gonna be impeached everyone's
gonna be a peach here's Keith Olbermann
broadcasting from his mother's basement
Republican senators and congressmen
finally speaking out against Trump on
Charlottesville on our pay Oh on the
response to hurricane Harvey on the
Secretary of the Treasury
watching the Eclipse while standing next
to 200 billion dollars in gold on the
military transgender ban the daughter of
the Secretary of the Interior herself a
veteran calling for his impeachment over
that a website run by a Republican
research firm noting with Sporn that in
one month Trump had attacked nearly one
out of every seven Republican senators
the little tendrils are popping up
through the soil so well fertilized by
seven months of this administration and
the president of both
Roger stones insurrection may in fact be
coming to pass except it will be
nonviolent and when it is over it will
not be good news for stone or his fellow
travelers oh and it ends there will not
be Trump see this is a great hope there
will not be Trump I say it very
seriously just like I used to say and
vlag Oh back on SportsCenter back in the
day this is the great hope okay again if
you're banking on this hope and you're
on the left let me recommend that you
get a better program stop associating
with antia and start providing some
solutions to the American people it
turns out that Republicans
their jobs the only consolation is the
Democrats are even worse at theirs
they're even worse at theirs Democrats
are now that CNN is now so desperate
about Trump that they're legitimately
attempting to push their own
presidential candidates it's an amazing
thing I was watching yesterday at the
gym CNN was on the TV and again I was
not I was in the middle of working out
so I couldn't go up and just throw
things at the TV but they decided to
have on John Kasich and and I think it's
John Hickenlooper I can never remember
Hickenlooper his first name he's the
governor of Colorado and they presented
yes John Hickenlooper and they were both
on with Brianna Keilar from CNN and
Keeler actually presented to them they
they were presenting their joint health
care plan that's going nowhere cuz no
one cares what these guys have to say
because John Kasich is a wadded up piece
of paper you stuck in your pocket and it
went through the wash and John
Hickenlooper
is is like a light ly weirder version of
Gary Johnson and so they're both sitting
there and CNN actually proposes to them
on the air that they should run a joint
candidacy for president a bipartisan
candidacy for president god no we
whipped up a little something just a lot
for why you know not dog powder okay
we're running for well you know the big
the big white house so we whipped up a
little something it's just a just a
little poster just to give you a taste
of what it would look like so I don't
know isn't that a little enticing
Governor Kasich
and then Kasich went on to avoid the
question I said oh no no you know that
I'd have to talk to my wife about that
I'm the only reason they're even
proposing these stupid health care plans
is because they want to run together or
they want like would anyone take John
Hickenlooper seriously as a human
running for president and look at the
guy you really think that's gonna be a
thing the loop loop de loop 2020 like
that's gonna be a thing kasich tried to
run last time and stayed in long enough
to get Donald Trump nominated and
everyone dislikes him because he's jerk
I mean I've been told I've been informed
on very good information that his father
is a mailman but that's about all that I
know to recommend him yeah but this is
how desperate the media are now they're
trying to push Kasich Hickenlooper as an
alternative to the awful crappy 2020
Trump Kamala Harris race that is sure to
come yeah okay so with all that
happening Trump this morning tweets out
that
he's basically been targeted by forces
beyond his control the truth is that
there is some of that happening okay
there's there's now a story out that
transcripts were viewed by the Senate
Judiciary Committee revealed that FBI
director James Comey had decided months
before the FBI's investigation into
Hillary Clinton concluded that he would
not recommend criminal prosecution GOP
chairman Grassley Senator Lindsey Graham
they all requested all the records
related to companies firing in the
transcript the FBI's principal deputy
general counsel of national security and
cyber law Tricia Anderson told the
Office of Special Counsel that Comey had
drafted a statement in early May that he
would later give in July 2016 that
legally exonerated Hillary Clinton so he
already decided he was going to
exonerate Hillary Clinton long before
FBI agents finished their work okay
that'd be good enough reason to fire him
right there
Comey was always a bad FBI director and
that is just more evidence of it so when
Trump says that he's been victimized by
a system that's in place clearly that's
the case and that by the way will be his
defense to anything that Muller comes up
with which is why I say it's not
necessary to fire Muller because I don't
think that they're gonna be enough
Republicans who even jump on board as
long as it seems that his investigation
has been compromised in any way I don't
think Trump has tons to fear from it I
actually really don't I think there'll
be a lot of bad headlines but I don't
think that he gets peached over anything
the Muller has to bring unless it
clearly implicates the president
directly okay time for some things I
like things I hate and then we'll do
some mailbag so things I like we've been
doing philosophy all week so this is one
of my favorite philosophical books as
you probably could have guessed
Machiavelli's at the prints so this is a
book that has gotten a very bad rap it's
it's short it's very readable it's
fascinating
written by and niccolo machiavelli from
back in during the Renaissance in Italy
and he was trying to advise trying to
get a job basically I believe was the
Borges and he was he was trying to make
it clear to them how he thought they
should govern he was trying to give his
his own book of little political advice
people identify Machiavelli as like this
evil sinister guy who's trying to
manipulate circumstances he was actually
proponent of what he called ver - ver -
as it's like virtue but it doesn't mean
like Saints who sacrifice themselves
necessarily virtue according to
Machiavelli means a certain quality of
manliness that allows you to uphold the
principles for what you stand so virtue
isn't just the values that you hold it's
how you
about defending those values and
sometimes that requires certain degree
of ruthlessness this is the handbook
obviously on political ruthlessness
every political science major has read
it as every political science major
should it is very readable it's very
readable so I tried to recommend
philosophy that's readable which is what
I'm not recommending Hegel or Kant but
Machiavelli is very readable the prince
it's a it's a terrific book and it's a
very short read it's again it's like 120
pages very short okay time for some
things that I hate so things that I hate
today I'm gonna show you two police
videos that I hate both of these police
videos but I want to explain why I think
the media jumps on one a lot more than
they jump on the other so there's one
police video that comes courtesy of this
department I believe this is in Georgia
there's a police officer and he pulls
over a woman and she won't get out of
her cars in Cobb County Georgia she
won't get out of this back in July 2016
just broke I think yesterday and she
won't get out of her car and she says
and he says why don't you take your
phone I'm arresting you why don't you
take your phone and call up your and and
I want you to call up your boyfriend or
something to let them know that you need
to be bailed out and she says I don't
want to take my hands off the steering
wheel because I've seen all the videos
cuz I've seen all the videos and
apparently she's a drunk driver and she
was drunk and kind of belligerent and
wouldn't get out of her car anything and
so the cop jokingly says well you got
nothing to worry about because we only
shoot black people right okay so idiot
idiot idiot terrible thing to say
obviously but does he mean that
literally I mean I'll let you watch the
tape it doesn't seem to me that he means
yes we literally go around every day
shooting black people it sounds to me
like he's got a drunk woman in the car
who's being an idiot and he thinks he's
joking with her to try and get her off
her guard and so he says the stupid
thing sarcastically like you got nothing
to worry about we shoot black people
hahahahaha right the same way that
steven crowder and I make Jewish jokes
right he's making a joke about how cops
are racist that seems to me what this
actually is he got fired over it here's
the here's the actual tape
[Music]
yeah we go black people right okay the
right at the end is the dead giveaway
that he's being sarcastic but it doesn't
matter obviously you can't save this
sort of thing because that's asinine but
he ends up being fired and this is
supposed to be some sort of indication
that the police know they're there
institutionally racist if I guess you
can read it that way that's not how I
read it I mean it seems to be pretty
obvious from the tape that what the guy
is doing is the lady says I'm looked at
all these videos and he's saying yeah
you've looked at the videos I know we're
all terrible but we only kill black
people even according to the videos so
you know get out of the car write this
or use the phone so he ends up being
fired for this this is a national story
okay this led NBC News today this led
NBC News here is a story about cop
malfeasance that to me is significantly
worse because this woman was a criminal
and she end up going to jail this
particular case comes out of I believe
Texas oh no I'm sorry Salt Lake City and
this is a video of a woman named Alex
wobbles she is a nurse and there was a I
see of the backstory there was a driver
who's trying get away from the cops he
was speeding in his truck trying get
away from the cops he crossed over the
median line and he went he plowed
headlong into a Mack truck he was badly
burned he was in a coma basically and
the cops come in they're trying to
absolve the other driver in the crash
they come into the hospital and they say
we want to take his blood okay it is
illegal under Supreme Court precedent
from 2016 to take somebody's blood
without any sort of probable cause
without a search warrant
or without the permission of the person
persons unconscious and there's no
search warrant so the nurse says listen
you know I may like you but I can't let
you take the guy's blood because that's
illegal okay they arrest her and they
brutalize her in the process here's the
actual tape okay no we're done we're
done you're under arrest as always we're
done
so they arrest her over nothing she was
never charged with the crime
they handcuffed her they dragged her out
physically okay she was the one who is
obeying Allah the cop wasn't and here's
the point of why I'm pointing and
comparing these videos most cop bad
action has little it has little or
nothing to do with racism it has to do
with cops just being crappy at their
jobs just like most of the things you do
in your daily job have nothing to do
with racism if you do it wrong it has to
do with you being bad at your job and if
it happens there's a black person in
front of you and you're bad at your job
you might be accused of racism the same
thing happens with cops okay Adam
Carolla makes this point all the time
and I think that he's exactly right if
you're a black person getting pulled
over by a cop and the cop was a jerk he
might immediately assume that it was
because he was black but being a white
person who's pulled over by a cop he
knows that it's just because some cops
are jerks right that I think it's a
perfectly understandable perspective and
when you're a member of minority group
that is the tendency you know my father
my grandfather I remember growing up
there'd be times where somebody would be
a jerk and my dad say the guy's probably
an anti-semite and I'd say dad it
probably isn't cause he's an anti-semite
he's probably just cuz he's an a-hole
right you know they're like dad that
happens like people are jerks I think
that you're a jerk is a better explainer
95% of the time than you're a racist and
so even the guy in the first tape it
seems to me he's acting out of ignorance
stupidity incompetence
he had 28 by the way the evidence for
that is the dead 28 years on the police
force before he was fired not a single
instance in which he was accused of
racism so you know that seems to me
better evidence than that tape of
sarcasm but the point here is that bad
police action we would be better off
talking about when police exceed their
mandate when police are brutal when
police are again out over what they are
supposed to be doing when police exceed
the use of force and when they do all
those things that seems to me a better
explanation of police behavior than just
blaming endemic institutional racism I
mean now it's levels is white they
didn't stop the Salt Lake City cop from
dragging her out for no reason
and if she'd been black what would the
headline have been all right I found
some levels him in a black
the headline would've been completely
different right it would white officer
drags black woman out of the ER black
lives matters would've been marching we
would have been told that this was just
unacceptable racism from the Salt Lake
City Police Department and we hear the
same thing whenever there's a whenever
there's a death I remember out here in
in Los Angeles in Orange County there
was a homeless white guy named Kelly
Thomas and who's beaten to death he was
diagnosed with schizophrenia was beaten
to death on the streets of Fulton in
California by a bunch of cops he was
white if he'd been black that would been
a national story it was like Rodney King
level I mean it was worse than Rodney
King as he actually died Kelly Thomas
and he actually didn't do not as much
wrong as Rodney King and it wasn't a
national headline in the same way
because he was white again I think the
same cops would be Rodney King beat
Kelly Thomas and I think they're both
wrong but that's a different kind of
wrong than racism necessarily okay time
to do a little bit of mail bag so
rouxelle or rochelle adler she says who
do you want to see sit on the Iron
Throne at the end of Game of Thrones so
I mean my personal preference would be
to - so Rob's head back onto his neck
and make him King I was a big Robb fan
and it was very sad to me when they
knocked him off I do like the theory
it's not right but I like the theory
that Ned Stark is still alive I think
that's hilarious and then he switched
places with Jake and Hagar in the in the
in the jail at the end at the end of
season one but yeah of the players who
are left on the board and in the Iron
Throne as I've said before my heart says
I would love to see tormund and Brienne
with their giant children but striding
the world I think torment would be a
good King because he's not interested in
ruling anybody else I think you but I
think that in all likelihood will end up
being a Council of advisers in a
democracy okay Janet says hello Ben how
do you think we can encourage young
Millennials to marry and understand the
importance of the nuclear family what
steps would you insist on taking when
you have the culture especially how I
would in the media teaching us that a
marriage and family are unnecessary well
I think that the first step that we can
take is when kids are young model great
marriages for them model great marriages
for them TV is modeling why it's great
to be single and it's all a lie okay how
many single people do you know who are
really happy about being single like
ecstatic about being single not that
they're happy they can be happy but I
mean just like about that aspect of
their life they're like yeah you know
what I love being single okay other than
a few guys who like to cat around
they're not very many people in the
United States
who are like yeah I love being single a
lot of people living together a lot of
people have girlfriends but they don't
get married because pop culture has told
them that marriage is a patriarchal
institution in which people are
miserable and they fall out of love with
each other and bla bla bla bla the best
thing you can do for your kids is model
a good marriage and everybody who's
married should model good marriages for
the rest of the world that's the single
best way to draw people toward marriage
marriage is an institution that does
make people happier by every pool
available both men and women are happier
married than they are unmarried
you know kids make you unhappy or in
some ways but a lot happier in other
ways that's a different question though
kids it's really fascinating how Western
civilization has made kids into dogs and
dogs into kids but that's that's a
different question than marriage itself
marriage itself is still an amazing
institution and it is a lifelong
commitment of somebody to you and
knowing that you're going to be able to
grow with that person the rest of your
life is a very different thing than the
idea that you have sex with random
partners so you get together with and
Bob you know I think that's garbage
and Nathan says do you tithe so Nathan I
don't I should yeah there's one area
where I come up short my own religious
observance and I'm moving toward it I
met with my financial planner the other
day and we were going to start laying
out some money toward that goal josh has
been and what is your position on
right-to-work laws and what is your
prediction for the right of the future
right-to-work laws in America so
right-to-work laws are great
right-to-work laws basically state for
those who don't know that there are a
lot of laws on the books in places like
California there was in Wisconsin there
is in Ohio that if you want to work for
the police department or the fire
department or the teachers you you have
to be unionized you have to work for the
teachers union so you can't actually be
employed by the state of California as a
full-time teacher without being a member
of the teachers union that's nonsense
it's garbage it's collusion it should be
illegal right-to-work laws basically say
that you do not have to be a member of
any Union in order for you to work and
also that they can't confiscate your
wages I mean the unions have the
government so sewn up there's a great
book called shadow bosses by a friend of
mine named Mallory factor and his wife
Elizabeth about this they're a bunch of
states that actually remove the state
will do this when they pay a paycheck to
a teacher in California they actively
remove your Union fee out of your
paycheck and give it to the Union okay
the Union is a private organization
that's insane that's like if I went to
all of my
employees and I said listen we have a
charity fund over here and we're gonna
use that charity fund for a bunch of
nice things and you have to give to the
charity fund and then the state says
okay well when we collect your taxes
we're gonna take out a little extra and
give it to your employer okay this is
it's totally nuts that this is how it
works right to work laws are a good
thing and not to be pushed Alexander
says do your kids believe in the Tooth
Fairy well they haven't lost any teeth
yet so I haven't actually had to have
that conversation I see nothing wrong
with kids believing in the Tooth Fairy
or the Easter Bunny or Santa Claus
believing life will disabuse you of all
sorts of notions later but I think it's
kind of charming I think it's kind of
charming and kids figure it out pretty
fast I mean the fact is the kids know
that it's really mommy and daddy but
they but they like them the mythology of
it is fun Taylor says hey Ben what are
your thoughts on red light traffic
cameras thanks Taylor so I'm of divided
mine on red light traffic cameras the
part of me that is annoyed with getting
tickets hates them the part of me that
says that the law should be equally
applied likes them so the the question
is whether red light traffic cameras
actually capture dangerous activity or
whether they're just prophylactic rules
that they are enforcing you know like
there are times when somebody is going
through the intersection and it's the
very last second and you're going
through a red light and there's no one
there is that somebody who deserves a
200 dollar ticket the same way that
somebody who runs a red light in the
middle of somebody else's green light
deserves a ticket I'm not sure I'm not
sure like there's some judgment calls to
this but if you want an equally enforce
traffic law I think that it makes sense
if you want to safer if you presumably
if you want to safer you know traffic
regime then you would have equal
application of laws and having cops sit
around it's even Strout let's put this
way red light traffic cameras are a much
better idea than hiring cops to sit
around your intersections instead of
policing actual crime this has been a
pet peeve of mine with the police for
years that has nothing to do the
officers I mean the other day I was
pulled over right near the offices a
couple months ago I was pulled over near
the office and I said to the police
officer thanks for everything else you
do and he kind of smiled and nodded at
me he said yeah
this is this is ridiculous because
they'd set up a one of these speed traps
and they had I think four motorcycle
cops and three squad cars just on the
side street over here to catch people
who are making illegal rights that's
like okay we got crime in the city like
real crime in the city even the cops
don't want to be doing that dantana says
hey Ben what's the best way to get over
a heartbreak
the best way to get over our heartbreak
is to get back out there not to sit
around moping about it if you sit around
moping about it then all you're doing is
you are is you are engaging in in giving
your the the control of your feelings
over to somebody else that's always a
mistake okay you are in control of your
own feelings you're a rational human
being do not give control of your
feelings over to someone else that
empowers them it does not empower you
and not to get all Marcus Aurelius stoic
on you but the fact is that it is up to
you how you decide to treat the
circumstances that surround you if you
get dumped if you have a heartbreak then
I would suggest that you you move on as
fast as fast as best you can in as quick
a manner as you can don't do this
routine where it's like well if I just
sit around everything will eventually
sort itself out it won't
Emanuel says assuming the worst
situation and that the investigation
drags down Trump what do you believe
what happened to the Republican Party
well Emanuel it sort of depends on
whether the Republican Party goes along
with everything Trump is willing to do
so let's say worst-case scenario
worst-case scenario is that there's a
direct letter from Donald Trump with
Vladimir Putin saying Vlad I need some
help you got any information on Hillary
Clinton and Vlad writing back saying yes
blue mold we have some information on
Hillary Clinton kill Matias enjoy we
would like to see you elected and Trump
race back saying thanks love it oh so
you can have Crimea right if Dad let's
say that's that's worst-case scenario
okay so if that happens and the
Republicans sit around and don't impeach
him then they end up going down with him
if they separate off from him they don't
as much remember a lot of Republicans
were getting ready to vote for
impeachment for Richard Nixon when he
resigned it seemed like a disaster for
the Republican Party and Nixon resigns
in what 75 I think and and by the time
it's over like six years later is Ronald
Reagan so the idea that it was the idea
that it was the end of the world when
that happened it was sorry it was it was
74 when Nixon resigned August 74 Nixon
resigned Gerald Ford fills out his term
there's one term of Democrats and then
go right back to Marit Ronald Reagan so
it doesn't kill the party to have a
president who's a failure it does kill
the party to have a party that endorses
the failure Megan says what's your
number one tip for conservatives in
college number one tip for conservatives
in college is keep your head down and be
be specific about the points that you
choose to make don't always go into
every
argument guns a-blazing understand what
the purpose of the argument is Brendon
says I want to know what your stance on
cussing is I know another podcast you
have a much more colorful language than
on your show but I'd like to know you
feel about cussing in regular life
thanks Brendon well I think you
shouldn't do it in front of kids
I think it's impolite I don't think that
it is a moral failing in any serious way
this is where I differ from a lot of
other religious people I may be wrong
I'm fully willing to to listen to that I
think that there are times when the use
of particular language is necessary and
appropriate I think everybody does over
curse but I don't think that it's a deep
abiding problem in society that Alya
let's put this way I think that the the
overuse of the f-word by everyone now
like when I was growing up no one used
the f-word ever it was just a thing you
didn't use the f-word now everyone uses
the f-word
I think it is a laxity in moral
standards that has led to the laxity and
language but I think that if you're a
person who drops the occasional f-bomb
when you're frustrated you're in the car
alone so I think that this is makes you
a lesser human being now I don't I think
that that's psychological studies have
actually shown that when you drop an
f-bomb it actually helps alleviate pain
and anger when you're in the car alone
by yourself like if you stub your tone
you all the f-word don't do in front of
kids don't do in front of other people
but if you do it'll probably make you
feel better than if you just didn't
Daniel says do you have any sort of
special show plan for when you surpass
Oprah and the iTunes ratings I don't
have any special show plan you'll get a
normal show you will knock out a car and
you will not get a car and you will not
get a car and none of you will get a car
go get your own damn car get a job Fox a
million sandwich rights is serial a soup
no cereal is not a soup I have two
things pursue but they're a bunch of
things that people think our soup that I
think are not soup okay so number one
soup has to be hot I know this is
controversial I know a lot of people
think you can have cold soup nonsense
there's no such thing as cold soup
that's called garbage okay no one should
be eating cold soup second soup has to
be cooked okay when you make of when you
make a vegetable puree and it hasn't
been cooked or you make a fruit puree
that's called a smoothie okay a fruit
smoothie is a puree when you give me a
bowl and it's just chopped up fruit can
they say oh it's a soup no it's not a
soup you're stupid okay Noah says Ben I
was wondering if you want any guns I
know how scoop scrupulous California is
and if you do what make and model I do
own a handgun I own a shotgun it's a
Mossberg 500 the shotgun and
Smith & Wesson 9-millimeter is my is my
handgun my Andrew says hi been during
the show we only ever see you sitting
behind a desk I must know have you ever
done an episode without wearing pants
would you ever consider it we wouldn't
be able to see anyway well first of all
Andrew you might be lying you might be
able to see me I just don't know and
that would be really sick and perverse
of you to get me to take my pants off
just for that purpose how dare you
second of all that I was implored to
wear shorts the other day because it was
101 that it was like a hundred and
ninety-seven degrees in the studio is
really hot two days ago I came in in
pants anyway this is the difference
between me and Michael moles and Andrew
Clavin I came in in pants
Andrew Clavin came in pants Michael
Mills came in naked and then stripped
off a layer of skin so he could be more
naked that's just - Michael moles is
John final question he says hi been my
fourth grader was reading a book written
for a second to third graders by an
author she likes only to discover the
central theme of the book was the main
character dealing with her two best
friends coming out as gay and her love
interest we hadn't decided whether who's
bi or not sounds like a delightful book
this brings me to my question when do
you think is the optimal time to broach
the birds and bees conversation with
kids do you think this is all the time
also the time to bring up LGBT issues or
is that a separate discussion it is a
separate discussion ok the
birds-and-the-bees is about human
reproduction it's not about sexual
pleasure the birds and the bees is about
what you do to make babies okay because
that is how the universe continues to
operate that's how the world continues
to function if that doesn't happen to
humanity ends what you do to make
yourself feel good on your genitals is a
different discussion then what is the
purpose of marriage and procreation it
is it's a different thing I gotta
remember when my dad gave me the birds
and the bees talk he literally sat down
with an Anatomy book and he said here's
how everything works and if you have any
questions come to me and I'm happy to
explain it to you and that worked out
great I asked my dad any questions that
I had any we were never shy in our house
about talking about the the way that sex
works and so you know I think that being
open with your child about how things
work is the best these issues will make
them self apparent that anyway I don't
think it's like you have to sit around
and wonder when do I tell my kid that
your kid will come to you with questions
if you're open about these issues your
kid will come to you with questions and
ask the questions and you'll be given
the opportunity to talk about them but
you should think in advance about how
you want to talk about these issues
because there are moral issues embedded
in the sexual pleasure question that are
not embedded in how sexual reproduction
work questions and that's a separate
conversation for my money I don't think
that are the same thing at all
and I think conflating the two is one of
the things
has done that's actually quite awful his
conflating the value of sex with the
value of physical pleasure I don't think
that that is the entire thing and I
think making the two identical has been
a real disservice to children throughout
the country okay
so we'll be back here next week we don't
have a show on Monday I believe because
it's Labor Day
so thanks commies appreciate it we will
be back on Tuesday and we will have all
of the news for you then I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]